[Music]
are we good
all right hello hi guys
how are you hi so good to see you
um welcome to the table my name is karen
miner
and i am so glad to be with you tonight
both here in the sanctuary
and a big hello to those of you who are
watching online
um yeah you can wait feel free to wait
but our online people and say hi
for those of you online if you could
take a moment just put your name in the
comments or say hello
let us know that you're watching we want
to make sure we can personally welcome
you
and make sure you feel connected here
with the table
i just have a couple of announcements
the first one
is it's may which means memorial day
weekend is coming up
and we will not be having church that
sunday of memorial day
we have a high value for rest and making
sure to give
our ministry team leaders and volunteers
and brett a break for rest and family
time
and so that's what we're going to do the
sunday of memorial day so we will not be
meeting here we won't be online running
a service so make sure to take some time
with those you love and rest and then
we'll resume the following sunday just
like usual
for the second announcement i'm gonna
have uh gary take it away with his own
special announcement for us all right oh
yeah that's right
so we are looking for some volunteers to
help with tech team
um so basically either sound or video or
the online
live stream or even some behind the
scenes stuff where
we put together slides or lyrics um
right now it's a pretty small team and
we need to have some extra people just
so that we can each take a break you
know like every other
week you know somebody gets off at least
once a month um
so anyways if you're interested in that
we could really use your help you don't
have to be super
techy talented it's really not that hard
we'll teach you
and so there's a card that you should
see around somewhere
just fill that with your name and your
contact information and just say tech
team
and you can drop that off outside in the
the wooden box out there right outside
the door and yeah we'd love to have you
thanks for your consideration all right
cool thank you
um so yeah the cards are dispersed in
various places around here on the chairs
if you're watching online and you want
to get involved in the tech team
we'd love to hear from you so just put a
comment in there just say tech team and
we'll reach out to you
and again that box is out there on the
little table
just outside the the door here if you
want to fill that out and you can just
write tech team on the card
and gary will get in touch with you we
also want to honor
our moms and mother figures today so i'm
gonna pass it over to mindy
and she's going to do that for us
[Music]
good afternoon you guys
all right we we wanted to read this
tribute
um we love how inclusive it is of so
many different journeys because
just because you are female does not
mean
that all of our journeys look exactly
the same and so we want to honor all of
those
today to those who gave birth this year
to their first child
we celebrate with you to those who are
in the trenches with little ones every
day and wear the badge of food stains
we appreciate you to those who
experienced loss
through miscarriage failed adoptions
running away or
the loss of a kid we mourn with you
to those who walk the hard paths of
infertility
fraught with pokes prods tears and
disappointment
we walk with you forgive us when we say
foolish things
we don't mean to mean to make this
harder than it is
to those who are foster moms mentor moms
and spiritual moms
we need you to those who have
warm and close relationships with your
children we celebrate with you
and to those who have disappointment
heartache and distance with your kids
we sit with you to those who lost their
mothers this year
we grieve with you to those who
experienced abuse at the hands of your
own mother
we acknowledge your experience
to those who lived through driving tests
medical tests and overall testing of
motherhood
we are better for having you in our
midst
to those who are single and long to be
married or mothering your own children
we mourn that life has not turned out
the way that you longed for it to be
to those who step parent we walk with
you on these complex paths
to those who envisioned lavishing love
on grandchildren
yet that dream is not to be we grieve
with you
to those who will have emptier nests in
the coming year we grieve and rejoice
with you
and to those who place children up for
adoption
we commend you for your selflessness and
remember
how you hold that child in your heart
and to those who may be pregnant with
new life both expected and surprising
we anticipate with you this mother's day
we walk with you
mothering is not for the faint of heart
and we have real
warriors in our midst
today we remember you
so wherever we find ourselves on this
journey
whether you are a mom or a dad or don't
have any children
tonight we just want to acknowledge that
we're all coming to this space with
different stories different pasts
and yet in our differences we come
together
in these moments to bless a god who is
near
and who is with us in the midst of
wherever we find ourselves so let's take
some time
to bless him together all right
bless the lord o my soul
oh my soul
i worship his holy
name
[Music]
seem like never before
oh my soul
our worship his holy name
the sun comes up
the sun comes
it's time to sing your songs again
whatever may pass before me
[Music]
you're rich in love you're rich
in love and your soul to
anger your name is great
and your heart is
i will keep on
ten thousand reasons for my heart
[Music]
worship his holy name
sing like never before
[Music]
still my soul will sing your praise
ten thousand years
[Music]
worship his holy name
i worship his holy
[Music]
oh my soul
bless the lord
[Music]
oh my soul
yes god thank you for being with us
in every season
[Music]
i love you lord
oh your mercy never fails me
all my days i've been held in your
hands from the moment i
wake up until
i lay my head
i will sing of the goodness of god
oh my life you have been faithful
[Music]
all my life you have been so
of the goodness of god
[Music]
i love your voice
you have led me through the fire
in darkest nights i am just
like no other
i've known you as a father
i've known you as a friend
i have lived in the goodness of god
[Music]
all my life you have been faithful
and all my life you have been so
[Music]
of the goodness of
everything
your goodness is
[Music]
is
your goodness is
running after me
[Music]
until my life you have been faithful
and all my life you have been so
so good
with every breath that i
[Music]
i will sing of the goodness of god
i will sing of the goodness
[Music]
of god
we're going to take a moment to enter
into
the prayer of the people so
if you want to lift up something that's
on your heart
someone's name maybe that you would like
to pray for tonight
or a situation or a people group
that might be on your mind this is just
a space for us to
come together as a community and
remember those
that we love remember those who are
struggling and
spend some time just bringing them
together before god
believing that he loves us and hears us
and cares about us
so i'm going to read a short prayer and
then i'll open up space for us
to say speak out that name or that
situation
and then i'll close us with a prayer
[Music]
also at the end of each line as i read
um there's going to be some words there
in a different color
and they're usually we pray to you
so if you guys want to join in with me
as i say the prayer and say those words
together that are in red
just another opportunity for us to come
together in this
[Music]
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community
and all those who live in them we pray
to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the widow and the
orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and
oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them we pray
to you
and lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us
and so now we lift these names to you
[Music]
do
oh my god
[Music]
for those whose names we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that we may have life
and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
all the poor and powerless
[Music]
and all the lost
and all the things to come confess
[Music]
and know that you are holy
and know that you are home
[Music]
we will
new
[Music]
unworthy
i know that you are holy
[Music]
we will cry
shout it
go on and scream into the mountains
go on and tell it to the man
[Music]
and he is
go on and tell it to the masses
go on and screaming from the mountains
go on
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
we will see
sitting down
[Music]
he is god
thank you god for your goodness for your
faithfulness to walk with us
on every path god be it be smooth or
bumpy
painful
or victorious we find you there beside
us
and within us leading us forward
grieving and celebrating with us
you are a good god and you are for us
thank you we're so grateful
it's in your name i pray all of these
things
and we say amen
wait
all right all right well good evening
everyone
grace and peace it's super super good to
be with you all and uh thank you
mindy and maggie and tyler and gary
for that beautiful time to worship and
just kind of re-center it's so good
isn't it to to just come on um
i do love how it's you know at times
sunday evening can be difficult but in
other ways it's kind of beautiful
because it's like that
this sort of deep breath right before we
go into the week
and what a refreshing time to just
recenter on god that's really really
beautiful
so thank you um team for lifting us up
and carrying us there
into god's presence so um i want to
welcome all of you
including those joining us online much
love
our extended table family and uh which
is bigger than usual with uh with kovid
we still have some folks watching
that way and then we have people just
kind of out and around even in different
states who
um tend to log on and join us which is
is awesome
and then i also want to welcome those of
you who are new here uh maybe this is
your first second third time you're kind
of you know settling in
and uh if that is you i want to uh name
that one of our values we have five
values here at the table
we want to be thoughtful inclusive
eclectic communal and vulnerable
uh that's a lot i won't go into all of
them that would be like its own sermon
um but the one i want to just give just
a minute to you is inclusive
and um you know we really we want to be
a place where
just regardless of you know whatever
all the the strange ways that humans
find to divide up the world
into us and them um whether it's along
you know racial lines
um class um gender
sexual orientation um even kind of
spirituality
and like you know denominations and
denominationalism
and it's kind of like this isn't really
my crew you know um and
what what all that kind of leads to is
folks come here and they kind of have a
question in the back of their mind like
i think i might be two something you
know
two rich two poor um
you know two two straight two queer two
two baptists two pentecostal you know or
something between
catholic you know whatever and it's just
i just want you to know like you're
welcome here
you're just you are just just as you are
we like you
we're glad you're here so take a deep
breath relax and
um and just know that you are you are
loved so um we are in let's see part
four
of our series titled new normal and um
this has been a fun series it's been
very timely i think because the
kind of the the whole premise or idea of
our of this series is basically that the
last um
you know 13 months or so it's been
really um challenging
obviously i think that goes without
saying probably no one's sitting here
like huh
what i think pretty much everyone's you
know tuned in
and so it has it's been really
challenging but what we've been
contending is that
i'm hiding within the challenge uh is
just a remarkable opportunity
because our normal um has been
completely upended
and with that it's the way i've kind of
thought of it is it's a little bit like
a garage sale you know you have a garage
sale and you kind of have to sift
through all of your things and make some
decisions
like what am i holding on to here what
am i keeping what's valuable
and what isn't it's just not serving me
anymore and it's time to let it go
and that's kind of where i think we are
as a people it's like but instead of you
know things that sort of like our life
and certain practices certain rhythms
certain beliefs and ideas
um ways we've done life and the pandemic
was kind of this opportunity
to kind of or at least on the back end
of it to kind of say okay what
all this stuff that's here what what's
good what kind of
um as jesus would say kind of was like
built on the rock
you know what was really a solid
foundation a good rhythm a good belief
um good relationships good practices
what was
really vibrant and i need to carry it
forward and what do i need to cut loose
and that's where i think we have just a
tremendous opportunity right now so
that's kind of what this series is about
is helping us establish and kind of name
some of those things like so that we
have a better
more vibrant new normal so um with that
in mind the title of my message tonight
is find the alleluia find the alleluia
and
our primary scripture is going to be
first timothy chapter 4
which says this this is the apostle paul
writing
he says for everything created by god is
good
and nothing is to be rejected if it is
received
with thanksgiving
i think this is a beautiful beautiful
passage that we'll kind of unpack more
but one of the things i think it's
naming that is it's pretty kind of basic
fundamental but it's very very easy
i think for us to kind of maybe overlook
it or it's easy to go unnamed kind of
unarticulated
uh and it's basically the idea that
um you know to be christian is to
believe
that not so much that just god is
like is kind of implies he's like a
thing in the universe like god exists
even people say that i believe god
exists
you know and it's like well i know what
they're saying but actually i think god
is the source
of everything that is right it's not
like he's like
like superman or something like in the
midst of the creative thing he's like
he's the source right the the reality
capital r reality even people of like
who aren't christians or have no faith
at all they'll often start capitalizing
their letters
you notice this like the universe
capital u it's like that little
that little capital sneaky right because
what's it saying it's communicating
the the more right i mean it's basically
without saying it oh my god that's what
you
god that's what we're talking about
right and and so to be christian is to
say
that god is the source of everything
that is which means um
everything that is is uh not just an
accident not random
but it's on purpose and that there's a
goodness
in it it's good and here's the thing
um because it's good and because
it's from god it's not only
like precious or valuable because you
know even someone maybe of no faith at
all might say like you know an atheist
or someone that kind of lives in that
story
um kind of maybe holds that things are
very precious because they're so fragile
they might say right
which is that's good as far as it goes
but i think to be christian is to want
to go even beyond that and to say it's
not only
things aren't just precious or valuable
but things are good and because they
come from god everything that
is is actually a gift
it's a gift i mean and i'm thinking
you're like what do you mean it's a gift
i mean
for almost everything not like evil
things i don't think evil like comes
from
or something but i mean just i'm talking
about you know the created world
everything from i don't know just all
the things you know from
um wetlands to um water
to um wine to sexuality
to relationship and the wind blowing on
your face i was standing right outside
um right before uh the service and i
could feel both the heat
kind of you know coming on me and even
that's good even though that texas i'm
getting a little nervous but it's okay
it's still it's good and i can feel the
breeze at the same time
it's like it's all it's all just good
all the
the joy and the the kind of um even kind
of messiness of
life right i don't know what's around
the next corner even that
is there's a goodness in it right it
comes from god
and it's and it's good all created
things come from god
which means they are all a gift
and another way to say that kind of
exact same thing
is that to be christian means we're a
people
who find the alleluia in everything
you say what is the alleluia that's sort
of one of those religious you know words
that's like i'm supposed to know what
that means i think it's awesome you know
but he seemed very enthusiastic when he
said it
um it literally means all hail to the
one who
is and uh that's basically an
old-fashioned way of saying
praise god that's what it is this is
to be christian is to find the praise
god
in everything in every situation um in
every
moment where the people um whose whole
posture
is just gratitude it's thanksgiving
it's hallelujah and amen and praise
god um now just to be i want to kind of
be clear anytime we start talking about
you know gratitude
thanksgiving finding the alleluia um
for some people it can kind of go off
the rails a little bit because it might
sound a little too easy you know it's
sort of like
almost like there's um i thought i wore
it almost like a cheap
gratitude um a a
oh how would i say it kind of a there's
sort of a version that's out there of
like a happy clappy christianity
you know that's like it's just it's all
good it's all good they're
evil there's no evil in the world
suffering huh i don't do you see
anything i don't see any suffering i
think it's fine i think everything's
great you know
and it's almost like in other words
there's a there's kind of a
cheap a too easy way of saying find the
alleluia and everything find the praise
god and everything
that's kind of you might say like on
this side of suffering like you kind of
have
an experience of suffering over here and
it's sort of when you're on this side of
it maybe
life has been relatively easy or you're
young or whatever it is and it's like i
mean you've had you know bad days but in
terms of like
real suffering like pain like
tears on your pillow at night kind of
pain
right when you're on this side of it i
mean to say you know find the elderly
and everything
i mean it's still true but it there's
something a little bit
and i think rightly so we're a little
bit suspicious that those folks are like
god is good all the time
all the time brother brother sister you
know it's sort of um
but here's the thing that same statement
from someone
who is on this side of suffering
oh that's not that's not some trite
little
plucky god's good all the time
i mean why because there was a cost to
it
it cost them something to say that and
and really what they're saying is
i have been to
the darkest moment and even there
god found me even there
christ met me and so here on this side
of suffering i can say alleluia and
amen i can say i'm gonna find the praise
god
in everything and in every situation
and now it's weighty and it's
beautiful and it's compelling and it's
true it's true and i think sometimes
cynicism though
kind of keeps us we see the people kind
of on this side of it and we're like
no i'm not going to say that i'm not
going to find the alola
right and we kind of get in this mode
and i think what we have to realize
is there's truth in the criticism but
it's not quite seen deep enough it
doesn't recognize that there's a way to
say those things
on this side where it's compelling and
it's beautiful
and it's true uh i i came across
or i should say i met um someone
recently
he's kind of a new friend i'm actually
getting coffee with him
for the first time this coming week i'm
very excited um but we met just a few
weeks ago
and um it was at don jacobs birthday
party don is uh
an elder here um elder he's part of our
elder leadership team here at the table
and so it was at his birthday party and
i just met this gentleman
um and he was i mean it's hard to
describe he was
very energetic he was very unique i i
liked him i was like i like
i like this guy and um in talking with
him
i realized i mean for one he he has a
deep deep
faith i mean he's um
yeah he's gone through some stuff and
yet it's like he's finding that alleluia
you know
and so in talking with him i realized
okay a he's got some deep faith and then
two i realized he was actually in the
midst of suffering in this
season of his life right now um and
talking with him he shared with me
basically he's
um he's he has cancer and so he is right
in the middle of chemo treatments
he's a you know i mean relatively young
man he's probably in his
early 30s or something um and it's just
going he's just going through it so
we've kind of kept in touch he lives i
think in las colinas so a little bit far
away
but i've just kind of stayed in touch
with him we facebook message
and um you know just kind of stay in
touch and i recently i
just kept a message just kind of
checking it had been a few weeks like
hey
how are you you know i know you're in
the midst of chemo and just catch me up
you know how can i be there for you
and i know he's watched a few times like
online who knows maybe he's watching
um and so you know a little connection
it's not like he's not a member you know
at the table or anything but just
a cool guy so we kind of stay in touch
and i sent him this message checking in
he doesn't write me back but he sends me
an audio message on facebook messenger i
didn't know this was a thing
um all of y'all are not in your head's
like of course all right well i'm just
out of it so he sends me this audio
message
it's like 60 second clips and so he
sends me like three
and it was kind of helpful because i can
hear his whole tone of voice
and honestly he sounded so full of joy
and i was like what is going on so
here's this is basically a transcript
i've kind of put in the i put the
messages together
and this is what he said so i'm just
checking in and he writes me this he
says or he tells me
well um brett i'm in chemo round
seven uh round eight starts tuesday
i spend 18 hours a day
pretty much obliterated and i mean i
just can't do much
but then i get six hours where i can do
stuff art painting
reading poetry he just starts listening
all these things
and he says and you know i'd say overall
it's pretty good i mean you know i have
side effects
that show up um neuropathy sensitivity
to cold
gi issues tongue goes numb sores in my
mouth
hurts to type i mean you know classic
typical stuff
i'm like listening to this i'm like oh
gosh i mean i'm upset when like i ran a
little fever
you know like or after the the when i
got you know the first shot the vaccine
was i'm not
feeling good you know ruining my week
i'm like oh my gosh this guy sounds like
job you know
all the things and he says but the
biggest thing i mean all that the
biggest thing it's the exhaustion
uh but you know i mean there's days i
just can't do anything sometimes i'm
like
what is going on in my life but
but i mean brett he said it's pretty
cool
let me tell you the school of suffering
it's a great school
it hurts but it's great
well brother he said until next time
be holy try to be a saint read the bible
pray to jesus
keep being awesome that's all we can do
do it to it my friend
and i'm like i'm listening to this on
you know it's audio and i'm like i mean
my jaw is just on the floor i'm like
and i mean the first thing that hits me
is like i thought
who's encouraging who here like i
reached out to
hey man you know i'm pastor i'm gonna be
there for you and all of a sudden he's
like hey just keep the faith brother
don't i know you're playing that church
that's hard it's a challenge
keep your chin up little buddy you know
like what is going
what's going on it's a good question
i think he's a man who's
beginning to learn to find the alleluia
in
absolutely everything
in every situation in every circumstance
i remember in another audio message he
used even i think he said that phrase or
something like
it like basically that god is good you
know god is good all the time that kind
of thing and
let me i mean didn't strike me as cheap
not at all
it's costly but oh he's learning
verse 4 everything created by god it is
good
and absolutely nothing is to be rejected
if it is received with thanksgiving
if you're taking notes you can jot this
down i can reject my life
in a spirit of complaint or i can
receive my life
in a spirit of thanksgiving the choice
is ours
the choice is ours and i was thinking i
mean the trick is of course it's so
um it's so difficult not to reject our
lives
um in fact i was even reflecting it kind
of it looks
a number of different ways i'm gonna
give you kind of three things tonight or
three ways that
three ways that we kind of reject i
think first a
um we tend to reject things kind of this
is back to the created things
that we're kind of like oh watch out
watch out for that watch out for that
watch out it's easy actually for
christians i kind of get in a very
defensive posture in the world
you know like bad bad bad bad bad evil
evil evil evil evil evil you know it's
like
and it's like all the things and it's
true that those things can be twisted
and misused right not trying to be naive
but it's we almost get in this posture
where we're just like
the path to holiness is just to reject
all the things in the world
um and this is actually paul's is
speaking to this um it's in the little
verse verse three right before the one
we've been reading over and over
um verse four this is verse three paul
says this
false teachers they forbid people to
marry
and order them to abstain from certain
foods
which god created to be received with
thanksgiving by those who believe
and who know the truth what it seems
like maybe is going on
here is paul is writing to a church
where there's some teachers he calls
them kind of false teachers in their
midst
who are basically have this posture it
could be that they think something like
sex sexuality is kind of bad is this
maybe that's what's behind the whole
don't marry
thing because it's kind of like of the
body you know
the body like dangerous and and then the
whole thing with foods
um this could be kind of a clean unclean
thing
um where you know you start kind of
having the off-limits foods the
the kind of holy religious foods and
those that aren't so it seems to be
something like this is going on in the
church and basically you can hear
paul saying like look be careful
of of labeling all the things like
no no no no like be careful because
you know it's there's something about
the heart and how you receive
something what's that there's that
famous verse god a man looks at the
outward appearance right people got the
outer appearance god looks at the heart
right it's very easy for us to get very
rejectiony and judgy
uh so we reject things um
second we reject people
this of course gets dangerous you know
where there's a sense of
i say now it's not things but now it's
people no
no no no no i don't like you
i don't like that person i don't um nope
they broke my heart i hate
them my ex my this my you know just
my boss my co-workers like they're
annoying they're you know whatever and
we get in this
mode where we start to go down this
dangerous path right of
of rejecting um rejecting people
um because it just it's probably they're
not living up to our standards in some
way
they're not religious enough not
spiritual enough
or if we're really not into that too
religious
too spiritual you know we just do man we
will find reasons to
to uh to reject so we reject people
finally third we reject
um just entire situations um
thinking back to my friend everything
he's going through right this is kind of
the first half the message is really
this is what we do and i think it's
applicable because i'm thinking of the
pandemic
right i mean how easy was it to get like
just a few months into that
and just say no i just i reject
i just reject this i i don't like it
and i want it to be over and so
i just i i refuse to be happy or
grateful
until i don't have to wear a mask
anymore right and like
well maybe it's better you wear masks to
hide that frowny face
you know but this is i mean this is the
posture right it's very easy to slip
into not just a pandemic but with so
many things of this posture of
of of speaking a no over situations
um especially of course um difficult
ones um and now i i do
i wonder um i wonder if i've persuaded
you though
i mean i can kind of hear maybe some of
your mindset or your what's in your mind
of the question of like look
i hear you brett like yes it's good to
be grateful
it's good i get it i shouldn't be judge
you i shouldn't reject as much but
here's the thing
some things are terrible
and some people are awful
and some situations are the
absolute worst
and honestly i just it's too
polly and i can't i can't get there like
i you just can't expect that somehow
you know by by loving god enough for
being grateful and like somehow i'll
just
transform these things into like
good and holy thing like it's just it's
not gonna happen
everything created by god is good
nothing is to be rejected if is received
with thanksgiving verse 5 for it is
made holy by the word
of god in prayer
i think this is absolutely remarkable
like let me kind of come out from this
angle what does he mean by like the word
of god usually when we read that phrase
we're thinking you know like the bible
holy scripture
and i think actually when paul uses that
phrase the word of god
i think he's he's normally meaning
something like the gospel the good news
of jesus
the the life the death the resurrection
of christ in embracing that and
proclaiming that
and i think what's so compelling and
remarkable about this text verse five
is that he's acknowledging like yes
there are things there are people there
are situations that are the absolute
worst and yet
when we when we approach them
in this heart posture of gratitude in
thanksgiving
when we when we come to them in a spirit
of praise and worship in in the spirit
of christ
when we approach things in a posture of
prayer that all of a sudden
what happens we we can transform things
that are like the worst thing
the worst person the worst situation and
all of a sudden what happens
those things those people those
situations become
holy become a god
moment where he is meeting
us in the midst of it
i um i have on fridays um
i'll close with this i have i meet with
a few guys and we are working through a
book called being disciples by rowan
williams
a christian writer he's the former head
of the church of england
but he's a wonderful writer and so we're
reading this book and
in a passage we came across a few weeks
ago he was talking about the difference
between being saintly and being a saint
and i loved this distinction he said
you know from the outside a saintly
person in a saint they like kind of look
similar because you know
they're like faithful and they're trying
to be obedient and you know
um i said but a saintly person
when you're around them you kind of get
the feeling
that they're better than you
and they kind of want you to know that
they're better than you like there's
like a little bit of
spiritual competition you know there's
like a little ego that's worked its way
into that religious kind of posture
right and it's like they're good and
they know they're good and they're
really trying to be good and they kind
of want you know they're good
and and he said the net effect is you
walk away from that encounter
and how do you feel worse
and it's strange because you think like
well they're like so you know
christiany or they're so religious and
spiritual and like i mean they're so
on top of it morally and yet you walk
away from the encounter and you feel
worse he said it's different with a
saint
when you're interacting with a saint
you come away from the encounter
and you feel better about yourself
because there's this complete lack of
rejection this complete lack
of judgment there's this sense of
humility
and and just a sense of hey i'm the same
as you and we're on the journey together
we're just trying to love
god like let's do our best can i
encourage you can i be there for you can
i
can i hold you and it's and you walk
away from an encounter with a saint
and not only do you feel good about
yourself like you actually feel
better than you are right like there's
almost this faith for
yeah i can do it
i can do this right i
god is on my side and i can overcome
with by his grace and like
i'm we're moving forward aren't we come
on buddy we're moving for and all of a
sudden
like from the outside they look so
similar and yet their effect upon people
is completely different what's going on
here
i think the saint has this whole heart
posture of gratitude
and thanksgiving and they're approaching
you
in every situation in that spirit of
christ the word of god in prayer
and what happens in that encounter is
that they are by god's grace
literally making you holy
they are what does that mean i don't
just mean that in some religious kind of
holy i mean in a very real sense they
are
drawing you towards god which means
they're drawing you towards the best
version of yourself they're drawing the
mind of christ
right into your your mind into your
heart into your soul
like you are becoming better from that
moment they are making you
holy and so i guess what i'm
naming is i think as a community when i
think of the table i don't want us to be
so saintly
let's not be so saintly i don't think
that's what paul's talking about here
like let's be saints let's be people
who are just ourselves but are meeting
god
in the midst of the journey in the midst
of the struggle in the midst of the pain
and he's doing a work in us and
and what this means is our gratitude
it's not just about us
i mean i could have given you all sorts
of scientific facts about like the power
of gratitude you know i mean it's true
it'll make you happier
all the things like all the psychology
of is true
but it's not just about you it's it's
about us as a community
drawing one another forward
and the people we interact with drawing
them forward
that sound good cool all right if you'll
bow your heads close your eyes
i'm gonna read normally i just say a
prayer but i want to um
it's just sort of a prayer it's also
sort of a
um just a word
from my friend that he
said told me
so until next time be holy
try to be a saint table
read the bible pray to jesus
keep being awesome
that's all we can do do it to it my
friend
amen
all right guys we're going to close out
a little different than
normal so if you'll stand with us
i don't know how many of you grew up
singing this song
probably not a lot of us but if you did
grow up like church of christ
bring out those harmonies all right and
if you didn't we're gonna sing through
it once all melody so we can kind of
hopefully learn it together and then
we'll sing it once more through
but it's just an old hymn that really
um hits home for this posture of
gratitude and thanksgiving
all right max you're gonna hit an e over
there
[Music]
all right here we go
whom all blessings flow
praise him all creatures
hear me lord
praise him above ye
heavenly hosts
[Music]
praise god from
whom all blessings flow
praise him all
creatures hear
me lord
[Music]
praise him above ye
heavenly
[Music]
god
oh
[Music]
awesome thanks you guys
hallelujah wow thank you that was
beautiful and so good to hear everybody
joining in as well that was that was a
moment
um thank you so much for being with us
tonight those of you in here
and those of you online um i was
watching the live feed and it's so good
to see the names
pop up there people that i know and love
and who are part of the table so thank
you for joining us
remember that we are a community i know
we're still in the midst of a pandemic
but we're also still a community and we
want to be there for each other
so both here you know before we leave if
there's anybody that needs
prayer or you just need an ear just
somebody to talk to
somebody to hear your story or what
you're going through we want to be that
for you so please don't leave until you
grab it doesn't have to be anybody
that's been up here on stage just grab
somebody around you
and say can i can i talk to you or can
you pray for me
um and then also just throughout the
week
if somebody comes to mind whether
they're part of the table community or
not
that's usually that's usually from god
somebody comes to your mind and maybe
it's more than a couple times
you're like i wonder if i haven't
thought about that person in a while
reach out
don't just leave it at a thought reach
out to that person
and say how you doing and it may be like
i'm doing great thanks so much for
checking in or it could be oh my gosh
i'm really going through a tough time
and then you have the opportunity to
to be with them and and and uh just be
there for them
so let's keep that in mind as we go
through uh the rest of the night tonight
and the rest of the week
so before we go out into our week i want
to leave you with a benediction
and i hope you'll receive this for
yourself very personally
because this is god's truth for you
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and on your worst day it's true
for the people that are surrounding you
right now and it's true
for people out there even and especially
people that you don't see eye to eye
with
so as you go into your week ahead with
all of its yet to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go filled with god's
holy spirit
and that same desire to extend those
gifts of unconditional love and grace
to everyone you come in contact with
this week
be blessed and we hope to see you back
here next week
[Music]
you